[Music]
emergency evacuation announcement should
be required to evacuate the building
you should always leave the building
near the nearest exit which is actually
this exit and down the stairs if you
need to back you do by the crew side by
the glass door and the external fire
escape staircase please hold on with
handrails if they're well slippery but
if anyone's unable use the stairs you
should allow others to exit the room
before they go to the fire escape door
where they could be given assistance our
assembly point is in the public carpark
side of the Civic suite please do not
delay your evacuation
please do not return to the building and
to give them permission to do so by
council staff please note this meeting
is audio recorded and can I please
remind you to switch off and mobile
phones or terminus terms of reference
with meeting and lasting committees to
exercise the council's functions under
the Licensing Act 2003 the gambling out
2005 and all associated or amending
legislation with the move on down to
agenda item number 1 with apologies for
absence
when it comes for Hawaii can still
holding like that's all I can say right
no one else right and any substitute
members and non-members attending
welcome County Council of Malcolm Adams
item number four consider the minutes of
the meetings held on the 12th September
2016 and of the licensing subcommittee
meetings held on the 20th of September
2016 the first of December 2017 the
fifth of March 2018 and the 22nd of May
2018 and now item 5 is to receive
declarations of interest no technology
and now we can move on to item 6 which
is to consider the report of the
assistant director legal services
seeking members approval of the draft
gambling a statement of licensing policy
in order to be published and circulating
for public consultation and you should
all have received
don't let it impossible documents
pops up around to each other the
licensing authority required to review
this document after three years our
current policy will expire in January
2019 the purpose of this committee is to
seek motor starts consultation on the
draft policy which has been amended into
account
and also changes to the small batteries
with regards to the casino resolution
members that is a resolution that we
need to decide every three years as well
and it can be a recommendation
recommendation that we submit to full
council when it comes back to committee
once we've had the consultation with
responses
I haven't got anyone questions
and customers advice Thank You mr.
chairman I have a concern I'm a little
concerned every doctor itself but I have
a concern over the consultation process
it says in here that the consultation
is to empower place businesses and local
residents
I know get to showing that I think the
objective of consultation is to obtain
responses and that's where my cancer
comes in this council and many Cass was
going to whatever managing director or
to recess for August other words nothing
is done about most a lot of
organizations for a similar concern
though August is very lightly started
yet the consultation process is claimed
to start by 30 July I impose at the end
of September if their objective is to
get responses and I'm assuming it is
then I would assume that you're not
going to get as many responses as you
can when you're putting information out
of that type which is the people seating
so I would think that perhaps that needs
to be revised and the start date of the
consultation needs to be like delayed
until September when the majority of
residents and organizations will be at
full strength and hopefully that will
enable us to get more comprehensive
response which is presumably okay thank
you thank you
any members views on though that we
should move the consultation period back
to the autumn then you have the holiday
period German concern would be there
that the mountain taking the students
bringing the new policy prophetic
January that's my concern with the guys
we all liked
suspicious
around six organizations such as no you
just apply and rescue the please Andres
Commissioner now please thank firing
current condition of Essex also to
William hero that Brooks Customs and
Excise Gambling Commission I just like I
mean I don't really feel it will affect
these races so my understanding for this
is these organized organizations don't
go into recess over this period due to
manufacturing it's MIT councils but they
can still put in data to the council
we're gonna have council staff they are
that's funny that was kind of linkage
and cancel with expensive lesson I'd
like to come back on that first place
the female versus Murray you makers has
recalled yourself says local residents
local residents of brand on a primarily
away can oldest I said that the big
dates of the presentation need to be
looked at but we've known about this for
three four years and I don't see that
that suggests if I have an excuse to do
not chinax and obtain the maximum and
then
ready so precise that you know putting
presentation out through illness that
causes September is acceptable there's
something but I would object to that
because I do think that it actually
disenfranchises as some people who would
otherwise have the opportunity to be
involved definitely because we through
the chance I'm German 211 has this plan
to entertain at home
additional taxes consultation
and we're going to propose that it stays
as it is
so the consultation period stays ease
we going to proceed with the actual
procurement yes
recommendation number one that subject
to any amendments required by the
committee the draft gambling licensing
policy statement 2019 2020 to pending
say is approved for commencement of the
consultation to rebreather and also a
recommendation to the likely timetable
for the consultation period be noted as
Appendix B
let's be in this meeting